特に質問はございませんでしょうか
はい じゃあちょっとマイクを回していただけますか
ボランティア ボランティアの方
マイク回していただけますか
少しマイク回してください
もう一回手挙げていただけますか
こばなしどうもありがとうございました
本日の話でですね 仏教は自分の心の成長を教える方法であるということと
他人のことをですね 管理するのはちょっと範囲外であるということではあったんですけども
ちょっと一人 私のですね
身近な人でどうしてもちょっと気になる人がいまして
お伺いしたいなということで参加させていただいたんです
で その人はですね 妄想に取り憑かれてしまって
もうそれが幻覚となって
本人にとってはもう現実として感じられてですね
そこから抜け出ることはできない
そういう状態にいます
で 周りの人はですね そういうものが見えるっていうのはとても信じられないとか
本人の思い過ごしだとか
そうは言うんですけども
そこからですね 出てくることはできない
どうしても本人にはそれは現実しか思えなくて
周りが自分を理解してくれない
こういうような まあ半ば精神分裂的な状態にいるというふうに感じられるんですけども
そこからですね 抜け出せる方法が何かないのかなと
ちょっと今考えていまして
何かサジェスチョンみたいなものがあればですね
教えていただきたいなというふうに思って
ちょっと質問した次第です
はいはい わかりました
えーと この妄想でね あのちょっと線が赤線がとん飛ばす
進んだらもうかなり大変ですよ
だから本人にとって 我々にとっては妄想ですけど
本人にとっては現実なんです
私たちも今妄想でいるんだけど
もうそれももっと悟ったら
これが妄想になっちゃうんだね
今 我々にはこれが現実で
ただレベルの問題だけなんですけど
もうちょっと行き過ぎですね
これが だからこの治す方っていうのは
誰かがこの理解する人が時間かけて付き合ってあげなくちゃいけないんですね
これはもう半年ぐらいでも付き合わないと治らないと思いますね
ちょっとしたはい これやってくださいというふうな
この注射という感じのものはないんで
なぜならば この妄想が長い間やってきて
自分の理性をもう潰してるんだから
また理性をおめか埋めてあげて
それでなくちゃいけないんだ
新しい種をね それができるカウンセラーがあればありがたいと思いますね
カウンセラーといったっても
友達だったら一番いいんですね
で そちらでも友達だったら一つ方便を教えてあげます
あの 決して本人の妄想は嘘やと言わないでください
本人にとっては現実ですから
これ 根掘り葉掘り それどういうこと？どういうこと
どういうこと？と聞いてあげてください
まず それでその言ってる現実にむちゃくちゃ矛盾があるはずなんです
ああ そうですかね でもこれはちょこっと変だなとかね
で そういう風にちょこちょこっとちょこちょこって言ってるだけでね
そこで話を聞いて理解すると
本人は信頼するんです
で それからこの信頼することで心がもう治り始めるんです
これ 妄想にふけってるのも
人を信頼しないんだからなんです
心の内は平気でもう恥も知らず
みんなに言いふらしちゃう人っていうのは
ものすごい健康的なんです
例えば悪い例なんですけど
あの 例えば若い男の子がね
ある女の子を見て結構美人やと思って
すぐまあお姉ちゃん 一緒にお茶でもどう？って
なんの前触れもない いきなり言っちゃうと
なんて失礼だと思うでしょ
でもあの男の子はすごい精神的な健康なんです
思ったことを正直に言っただけで
ダメ あ そう で 出ていくだけですからね
問題ないんですよ ですから
この でも我々にとっては心の内がね
そう簡単に言えないし
言ったらまずいし 自己制御も必要でしょうしね
そういうことで この何も自分の気持ちは誰にも言うことがなくなると
妄想になっちゃうんです
エネルギーは逆回り 内回りになっちゃうんです
だから まずずっと話聞いてあげてください
ああ そうですか 今日は 1時間話聞いてあげますよとかね
それで自分にも仕事がありますから
じゃあ時間だからね また明日とかね
そういうふうに自分のことも気をつけてください
しかし 言うことは一つも否定しないこと
ご自分が勉強してください
この人はどんな妄想をしているのか
これは欲の場合は何ですか？どんな欲を抑圧して
どんな怒りを抑圧したからこんな妄想になったのかどうか
ご自分が研究してください
それで相手も治っていきます
何もする必要ないんです
ただ話を聞いてあげてみてください
それで信頼が生まれてくると
本人もニコニコと まあやっぱり妄想だなとか
これはとか言ってくれたりする
そうするともう結構もう治る方向に行ってるんです
だから まあそうでもしょうがないでしょうとかね
自分が慰めてあげる そういう風にちょっと時間かかりますよ
まあできる範囲で頑張ってみてください
はい はい 他の方はご質問ある方が
初めまして 私はバレエの教師をしておりまして
教えることを通してすごく悩むことが多いんですけれども
先生がおっしゃる瞑想法すれば
自分が今悩んでいることの答えが自分でわかるようになるんでしょうか
それをお聞きしたいです
まだ私は瞑想すらもしたことがないので
ちょっとアドバイスをいただきたいと思いまして
瞑想っていうのは そういうちょっとした問題に使うものじゃないんですよ
だから あの うーん 瞑想する人にとっては
ほぼどんな問題でも解決できると言えないわけじゃないんですけどね
先生何て言ったっけ？バレエ
バレエの先生よ 踊り 踊りの方の先生
はい  で だから具体的に何に悩んでるかっていうことを私は知ってるならばね
まあ具体的なアドバイスはできますけど
いいですか？ はい  えっとですね
例えば いい教師が必ずしも人を集められる教師ではないっていうのは
私たち教師の中でよく出るんですけれども
私はまあ バレエというものを通して
教育というものに携わりたいなという思いもあるんですね
そうすると まあ厳しい
今の時代厳しすぎるとか
なかなか親御さんからも理解が得られない
要するに甘やかしみたいな時代ですので
そうすると経的には生徒が減る
で そこにすごく私はジレンマがあります
はい それだったらね あのお母さんたちに先に言ってください
このお子さんたちはかなり上手な上手に踊るようにしてあげますけど
それだけでは何の意味もないんだと
この世界ではすごい真面目な
ものすごい自己コントロールできる
感情コントロールできる立派な人間も育てることが
バレエの本心 本心というか
本当の目的であると バレエというのはただかっこよくて踊るだけじゃないでしょう
ご存知でしょう 大人だから
これはもう苦行そのものだと
でしょ だから 私もすごく怒ってますよ
このバレエダンスを開発したあの人の人にはね
いかに難しいポーズするのかと
不自然なね だから見てる我々にとってはかっこいいんだけど
当然当たり前でやる人々はもう拷問だ
そうなんです そこに私は今自分で気づいてるんですけど
私が食べていく道っていうのがバレエを教えること以外になくて
そこにすごいジレンマがあります
すごく ですごく自分で悩んで
自分でこう分析して答えを
はい 考えないでください
あのバレエでは体はもう厳しくコントロールすると
それによって心だよ心だよ
気持ちだよとかね ちょっとちょっと痛くたっても忍耐するものだよとかね
笑顔 笑顔とね いつでも本気で笑ってくださいと
笑えないでしょ こんな苦しいんだからね
これがすごいやと だからもうバレリーナっていうのはすごい人だと
すごく苦しいのにニコッと笑っていてとかね
だからこれで君たちは世界でどこへ行ったっても大物になりますよと
だからそこを教えるように
人格を作るようにと そういうふうにプログラム書いてください
お母さんたちにも言ってあげてください
そうすると あまり厳しいということはない方がいいんです
だからもう だって元々厳しいんだからね
だからただお母さんたちはバカだから
かっこよくって振り回ってくればいいというふうに思ってるだけですからね
そんなことだったら逆だからね
自我が張ってる女の子ばっかりになっちゃうでしょ
あの子には誰も結婚相手がなくなっちゃう
そんなもの だから いかに中からね
もう忍耐もする 我慢もできる
もう苦しいなのにニコッと穏やかに笑える人格のある人を作るのかっていうことがね
だってバレエバレエバレエ開始来る来る
みんなバレリーナにならないでしょうに
まあただちょこちょこっとした塾の感じで来るんだから
その中でものすごい抜群の才能ある子が出てきたら
そこはもうあの石川遼さんみたいにね
その人は一流になるでしょうね
すごく気楽に捨ててください
いや ガチャガチャ考える必要ないんです
どうせ踊りだよという感じでね
話もね それで解決すると思います
はい はい まだ質問がございますら
すいません えっと ちょっと遅く来たのにお聞きしたくて質問させていただきます
えっと 罪けとしてお聞きするんですけれども
えっと 自分の親がおそらくまあ不幸であろうと思う
思う時に えっと まあ自分家族
が明るい気持ちでほがらかに生きられないでいるんですけれども
うん まあもちろん仲が悪く悪かったり
離れ離れになってたり
いがみ合ってても まあ本人たちはそれなりに笑って暮らしてるだろうと思えば
まあ大してこちらの心持ちにも負担はないんですけれども
えっと  家族とかがまあ離散してるとか
連絡もうまく取れないとか
まあ複雑な気持ちはあるでしょうけれども
あの怒りとか憎しみとか
そういう状況を持って
それぞれバラバラに孤立して生きてるだろうと思う時に
なかなか明るい気持ちで自分の人生を歩むのが難しいんですけれども
今質問する時に罪けとしてと聞いたのは
おそらくあの仏教の考えから言ったら
まあ身内にいろいろ問題があったって
ちゃんと生きなさいというような教えがあるんじゃないかと思った上で
ちょっとお聞きしたいなと思って質問させていただきました
お願いします  家族はね
まあ一緒に色のありそうっていうことかないと思いますけどね
家族があっても 一人一人一人がね
大人になって独立するんだから
バラバラになるのはもう基本ですよ
だから年取ってくると
両親には仕事をできなくなってくると
子供が徹底的に面倒を見てあげなくちゃいけない
そんな程度ですよ 家族って
それから自分が結婚して家族を作ったら
そこで新しい家族が現れるだけです
しかし それの最初のゴールはバラバラなんです
バラバラにならなかったらダメなんです
結局は 子供は産んで育てましたけど
今 35歳だけど まだ一緒にいるんだと
ものすごい問題でしょうね
もう子供を作って女の子なんですけど
28 で結婚しちゃってね
それっきり 2回  3回来たんだけどね
今孫 2人いるみたいんだけど
全然出てこないんだと言ったら
最高に成功してるんですよ
本人が向こうの家で忙しくて
もうもう親のことはもうもうもうもうもう暇がないっていうね
だから本当はそれが自然の発展なんです
いつでも家族はベタベタベタベタいるもんじゃないんです
やっぱり独立しなくちゃあかんでしょ
だからそれほど考えることではないんですが
だと思いますし それから仏教ではね
サーリプッタ尊者の話紹介します
サーリプッタ尊者っていうのは智慧の第一
人類の中でブッダの 2番目という
しかしすごい謙虚なお坊様でしたから
体弱かったですから まあずっといつも控えめにいるんですね
お釈迦様 それに困りまして
こんなに智慧の第一人者が仏教の前に出てこないと困るよと
いつでも引っ張るんですね
時々自分が弟子 新しいお坊さんたちでね
もう挨拶ぐらいして サーリプッタ尊者になってくださいと追い出すんです
いて サーリプッタ尊者に指導してもらったりもする
そこまでの素晴らしい方なんですね
しかし サーリプッタ尊者のお母さんがバラモン教で
邪教で もう仏教大嫌いなんです
大嫌い もう腹が立ってるんです
息子が出家したことに
だから衣着てる人を見ただけでも侮辱を焼きたい放題
サーリプッタどうすればいいんですかね
どうすることもできないんですね
ずっと黙ってたんです
そこでサーリプッタ尊者はもう先に亡くなられたんですから
ちょっと自分の寿命が終わってきたんですね
出家生活だからね もうすごい苦しかったでしょうね
で 体もちょっと弱かったり
お腹がすごい病気のような病がありましてね
かなり強烈でね 多分結構大変になったこともありまして
で それでやっぱり寿命になりましたね
なったところでお釈迦様にお釈迦様
もう私はこれで涅槃に入りたいと思いますと
ですから 最後に最後の日はね
母親の家に戻りたいと思っていますよと
お釈迦様はどうぞどうぞと
その日も最後 お母さんのところに行ったんです
お母さんがもう普通に喜んじゃって
まあ息子は侮辱してはいかんだからね
いくらなんでもね やっと戻ったっていうことで気にしない
あなたの部屋にあれ えらい態度がでかいね
このお母様は まあしかし
どんどんどんどんいろいろできることがあって
やっぱり自分の息子はものすごい人だとわかったんです
ものとんでもないすごい人だとわかったところで
じゃあ君の教えは何なのかと話を聞いて
それで仏教を理解して悟りに達するんですね
で サーリプッタ尊者はそのまま涅槃に入ってしまいます
だからたった一日で親孝行するというね
今までもう無視しちゃったんです
まあそんなもんだから
まあですから サーリプッタ尊者は仏教の第2番目
ブッダ 1番目 サーリプッタ 2番目
しかし そのお母さんと言えば
もう邪教そのもの 凍り固めて子供の色を見ただけで
侮辱 侮辱 冒涜とか  それでいいんですよ
もうそれぞれの道だからしょうがないでしょ
時期が来たらなんとかなりますからね
そういうことで このあまりにも家族のことで悩む必要はないんじゃないかなと思います
で 家族は一緒にいてほしいのは子供の時だけ
あの連中はちゃんと親の言うこと聞いてほしいんです
しかし 高校生になってくると
どんどんどんどんどんどん自分一人で生活することはしっかり学んでもらわないと困ります
一旦大学に入ってからはもう家に戻って欲しくないんです
そのまま卒業して そのまま就職して
それでそれで社会で旗を立ててほしいんです
まあ夏休みぐらいは帰ってくればいいんです
それでも早く帰った方がいいんですよ
面倒くさいんだからね
だからそんな程度で考えてください
そんな大げさなことではないと思います
だから出家の場合もありますよ
今 現代にもありますよ
カトリック教の家族なんですけど
当然息子がカトリックを嫌になっちゃって
嫌になっちゃうと家から破門でしょ
で 出家しちゃうとかね
いますよ それって親孝行できるわけないで
その場合は それでそれぞれの道を歩んでいるんだからね
そこまでは社会の問題解決できませんよ
はい どうします  それではあの
だいぶ時間が押してきましたので
そろそろ終了したいと思います
それでは最後に皆さんで回向の文を行って終了したいと思います
合掌してください 回向の文
仏法僧の三宝に礼拝致し
戒を守り 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって積まれたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして苦悩が減らえますように
サンビーティヨー ヴィヴァンジャントゥ サッブローゴー ウィナッサトゥ マーテー バワッタンテーラーヨー スキーディーガー
ユコーバヴァー ババトゥ サッブ マンガラン ラッカントゥ サッブ デヴァター サッブ ブッダヌバーヴェーナ
ー サダー ソッティー バヴァントゥテー ババトゥ サッブ マンガラン ラッカントゥ サッブ デヴァター サッブ
ダンマヌバーヴェーナー サダー ソッティー バヴァントゥテー ババトゥ サッブ マンガラン ラッカントゥ サッブ
デヴァター サッブ サンガヌバーヴェーナー サダー ソッティー バヴァントゥテー アビ ワユラーローギャ サンプッティー
サッブ サンプッティー メーヴェーチャー アトゥ ニッバーナ サンプッティー ミミナーテー サミンジャトゥ
サーフサーフサーフ  では大変長い時間拷問されちゃって申し訳ありませんでした
どうもありがとうございます
ありがとうございます